Je suis Tony Stark,
je construis des trucs sympas, j'ai une super fille
et parfois je sauve le monde, alors pourquoi
ne puis-je pas dormir
[Musique]
tu m'as élu sur une seule plate-forme Je
défendrai ce pays à tout prix
le mandarin doit
t'arrêter  ne sais pas qui je suis
tu ne me verras jamais venir
le monde entier va regarder la
question où est Tony Stark les choses sont
différentes maintenant je dois protéger la seule
chose sans laquelle je ne peux pas vivre c'est
toi il y a la star
la  le premier jour c'était la gauche de ta
vie
je vais offrir le choix veux tu
une vie vide
ou une mort significative
tu n'es pas un homme tu n'es rien de plus
qu'un maniaque
je n'ai pas peur de toi pas de politique ici
juste une bonne vengeance à l'ancienne,
nous avons besoin de renfort, c'est votre département,
voici mes garçons
[Musique]